here's the neighborhood right across the
street and this home bought me a dozens
of homes here are destroyed by the high
winds that came through and if it was
indeed a tornado that came through this
area but look at all the sheet metal
that wrapped around that utility pole
right in front of this house bit more
damage here's a couple of commercial
buildings that one has some damage and
this one has very heavy damage I have no
idea what kind of business this is but
that looks like it is a war zone and I
described an apartment complex earlier
as looking like a war zone but you look
at this and you see the heavy damage to
some of these homes some of these homes
with minor damage other ones completely
leveled and again neighbor helping
neighbor we've seen a lot of that this
tornado actually took a little bit of an
easterly to the southeast path when
normally we see tornadoes go to the
Northeast from the southwest of the
Northeast but that doesn't seem to have
been the case with this one so be a lot
of need here in the Dayton area as
people trying to recover from this storm
I'm Dan Carroll in chopper 9
[Music]